joga-se estão vendo nessa imagem estão
vendo uma criança tomando um remédio é
uma cena comum em 1 a 1 teria nenhum
problema não teria nenhuma polêmica em
relação a essa cena não fosse o único
detalhe a natureza desse remédio
essa criança está tomando um remédio à
base de cannabis
essa é uma das tantas crianças com
epilepsia refratária uma doença
incurável de convulsões frequentes
intratável pelos medicamentos atualmente
disponíveis que vê nessa planta a sua
esperança cannabis medicinal já é uma
realidade no brasil desde o ano passado
desde março de 2016
a maioria das pessoas não sabe disso a
maioria dos brasileiros ignora esse fato
esse processo é um processo que foi o
que vem sendo iniciado pelos pacientes e
impulsionado pela internet pela intensa
troca de informações sobretudo com
outros pacientes dos estados unidos é
que subitamente os pacientes brasileiros
os brasileiros descobriram que várias
patologias podem ser tratadas ou teriam
seus sintomas aliviados pelas
propriedades curativas dessa planta
olha que interessante nos estados unidos
tudo começou há algumas décadas atrás
com os pacientes hiv positivos depois os
pacientes com câncer
buscando a adjuvante para o tratamento
para a quimioterapia
desculpem a e depois pacientes de
esclerose múltipla um tipo de doença
neuro-degenerativa no brasil tudo é
muito mais recente e foi pelo psi
refratário particularmente epilepsia
refratária infantil que trouxe esse tema
de novo pra mídia trouxe tema de novo na
moda por exemplo eu falei infantil é
isso mesmo crianças sendo tratado com
remédio à base de cannabis
mas onde é que essas pessoas têm acesso
a esses produtos
afinal a gente está falando de um
produto legal né mesmo tem duas formas a
primeira forma é ter acesso a produtos
importados que aqui no brasil não
poderiam ser considerados medicamentos
mesmo no país de origem eles são
suplementos alimentares
a segunda forma e que muitos pacientes
têm recorrido porque a importação ainda
é cara ou seja eles não têm acesso
nessa segunda forma é o cultivo caseiro
ea preparação na cozinha de suas casas
do próprio remédio é isso mesmo
então vocês vêem as famílias dos
pacientes as mães discutindo coisas como
você sabe se essa variedade da planta é
psicoativa
ela tem tetrahidrocanabinol thc o ala
majoritária um canabidiol cbd a alguém
tem alguma informação sobre o perfil de
ter penas dessa planta parece maluquice
né
ninguém aqui que precisa tratar o seu
filho um parente de se discutir esse
tipo de coisa parece uma sopa de
letrinhas e as mães estão se deparando
com esse tipo de obstáculo estão
enfrentando esse tipo de obstáculo e
essa força energia ela literalmente move
montanhas
eu mesmo apesar de ter uma carreira de
15 anos especificamente na farmacologia
dos canabinóides foi trazido para dentro
desse furacão por conta da interação com
os pacientes
essa foto que vocês estão vendo é
provavelmente a primeira análise química
preliminar de olhos é feito no brasil
importados alguns dos pacientes que se
tratam com esse tipo de substância os
voluntários de pesquisa quando
trabalhava no rio de janeiro
no estudo há um projeto em parceria com
o doutor eduardo favor e um neurologista
famoso especialista em eclipses e que
foi um dos precursores disso no brasil
ele acompanhou esses pacientes
e apesar dos pacientes estarem tendo
benefícios apesar de os produtos estarem
funcionando
ele não tinha idéia do que tinha lá
dentro e muitos continuam tendo a idéia
é uma situação muito desconfortável é
você tomar algo que te faz bem por outro
lado você não sabe o que tem lá dentro
e foi por essa porta tentando ajudar a
atrasar um pouco de racionalidade para
esses pacientes para esses tratamentos
que entrei nesse processo tentando
ajudar essas pessoas
e tudo isso só é possível porque a
percepção em relação a esse tema está
mudando enormemente nos últimos tempos
essa pessoa que vocês estão vendo ainda
slide ou dinant um pesquisador britânico
que resolveu fazer um estudo do dano
potencial que as drogas podem causar às
pessoas mas incluindo também o seu
entorno
sua família seus amigos o trabalho e
adivinha o que ele descobriu que se você
considerar assim a cannabis é somente a
oitava droga ele é considerando as
listas e as listas
neste ranking curioso na e uma pessoa
assim falando isso não parece uma coisa
comum que a gente está acostumado
defendendo essa planta não é pois é a
ciência já sabe que a cannabis pode ter
um efeito terapêutico na epilepsia
refratária faz bastante tempo
o primeiro artigo a linkando canabidiol
e epilepsia já tem mais de 30 anos e ele
é ele foi escrito por um brasileiro
veja que interessante a gente tem
brasileiro sendo pioneiros nessa
história em todo o mundo e apesar de já
saber disso há mais de 30 anos
os pacientes que procuram tratamento
hoje estão relativamente desemparados
salvo alguns raros exemplos
quando um paciente vai ao médico buscar
esse tipo de tratamento o que ele ouve a
não há evidência ou não posso te
escrever ou ainda a não sabemos se é
seguro
parece uma uma posição relativamente
confortável do médico né
o paciente saiu na frente com vários
problemas tentando buscar uma cura um
alívio uma solução do seu problema e ele
simplesmente cruza os braços e fala não
não há evidência mas também é muito
fácil da nossa perspectiva julgar os
médicos e eu gostaria de dizer que isso
não é justo porque eles também estão
perdidos
eles também estão desorientados o que
está acontecendo na cannabis medicinal
hoje é exatamente o oposto do que toda a
indústria farmacêutica está acostumada e
do que mesmo os médicos estão
acostumados no processo normal de
desenvolvimento de um medicamento em
geral se descobre uma nova substância o
novo álbum farmacológico se dedicam
vários anos de pesquisa com muitos
especialistas
vários assuntos diversos a esse registro
medicamento a esse medicamento produzido
e só então as pessoas têm acesso o que
está acontecendo na cannabis medicinal
exatamente oposto
as pessoas estão tendo acesso a ciência
está crescendo com isso está se juntando
muita informação a respeito disso e
baseado nessa informação e nessa
experiência é que estão sendo gerados
produtos é exatamente o oposto
e é um processo com uma velocidade
estonteante e que está apenas começando
no brasil é um processo iniciado pelos
pacientes catalisado pela experimentação
é e é um processo que pode ser
relativamente diferente em cada país
onde ocorre a patologia diferente as
pessoas são diferentes as reivindicações
diferentes mas o formato é geralmente o
mesmo
tudo começa com a judicialização os
pacientes reivindicando acesso a esse
tipo de produto na justiça passa por uma
fase de facilitação de importação de
produtos de outros países que é
exatamente o ponto em que a gente está
no brasil e que já atende mais de três
mil pessoas de maneira legal e evolui
para uma regulamentação completa que
deve acontecer no brasil ainda este ano
ou no mais tardar no próximo
a coisa está indo muito rápido e com um
poder imenso e é só um cenário de
regulamentação completa que essa
indústria pode existir
e qual é a contribuição dela baseada na
experiência dos pacientes baseado na
experimentação continua neste monte de
informação gerada pela ciência
a indústria entra com um processo
reproduzível reproduzível escalonável e
confiável de produção de medicamentos
e é exatamente isso que a gente está
fazendo neste momento no brasil ea
partir da planta o que é muito legal pra
mim pessoalmente é que eu consigo
conectar tudo o que eu aprendi ao longo
da minha carreira com este objetivo com
esse foco principalmente uma coisa
chamada de efeito entourage
a idéia de que há um potencial sinérgico
que contribui para a terapia quando você
usa uma planta como um todo esse ano
realizei um estudo que é chamado no
estudo de meta-análise reunir sete
estudos diferentes juntando informações
de 442 pacientes e os resultados são
muito positivos assim em evidência de
eficácia e de segurança
esse estudo foi apresentado este ano na
faculdade de medicina de harvard
para vocês terem idéia de onde é que se
esse tipo de assunto é está sendo
discutido hoje em dia é coisa muito
muito sério é o processo que está
acontecendo hoje
dentro da empresa a que eu libero e do
processo que lidera junto com outras
pessoas
é um processo de juntar conhecimento
ancestral e tecnologia de ponta
a gente está empreendendo uma luta com a
motivação de usar todo o potencial dessa
planta e corrigir alguns erros do
passado que infelizmente associaram a
este tema a violência e preconceito
estamos lutando para usar todo esse
potencial e fazer a planta seguir a sua
vocação natural de curar pessoas ao
invés de levá los para a cadeia
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]